the Joe Rogan experience Jocko I don't
even know how you stand politically
which lares cuz you're one of the few
guys that's just not defined politically
online because people think of you as
such a savage they leave all the
politics out of it
there's god I don't know what he's get
up gets up at four o'clock in the
morning leaves a puddle of sweat
he's America he's Team America like it
seems like you don't have this thing
with like left or right you don't have
this right or left distinction ya know
what's really interesting if you look at
the demographics of like the people I
meet when I go and speak it's it's
everyone it's everyone from every
different spectrum and I can yeah I'm
just talking my political beliefs are
like hey I I believe in individual
freedom well that seems to me it's kind
of hard to argue against that right yeah
yeah I believe in individual freedom and
with that goes some level of individual
responsibility mmm yep okay I don't
think the government is the great
solution to a lot of our problems you
know so for me it's like a smaller
government probably a better thing and I
think probably why you get this
impression from me is I actually have a
balanced I I believe that the solutions
are somewhere balanced and in America
right now that that doesn't really get a
lot of traction because everything is
broken down into such little tiny sound
bites of you're either Pro this or
you're against it and there's no gray
area and by the way if you believe this
you know if you believe yes and I
believe no I actually hate you that's
and I'm going to attack you and that's
why when when I started going back and
forth with Tulsi like I you know I kind
of get a gist of what she thinks no I'm
like oh cool guess what I think she
surfs she trains martial arts she plays
she plays ukulele no I mean I can hang
out with her name she even if our
political beliefs aren't 100% aligned
which my political beliefs aren't 107
aligned with anybody does that mean that
I hate her and I'm never gonna talk to
him to call her out no actually it's
like oh cool oh that's an interesting
perspective because one thing that gets
tied into all these things nowadays is
our ego right our ego we paint ourselves
into a corner where it's like I believe
this and now the last thing we can do is
is say I actually know what I that's a
good point Joe you you
you thought of it from that perspective
before and also just thinking of what
other people's perspectives are because
you know you just talked about single
moms well you got to take that into
perspective because it might be easy for
me to say because I've got kids but I
got a wife and and we can make things
happen but although single moms over
here working two three jobs you know you
always talked about me getting up at
4:30 in the morning and I always say
look there's single moms out there that
are getting up at 3:30 in the morning to
go work their first shift at the diner
so they can get to their second shift at
the grade school or whatever they're
working so they could do their third
shift that's some other restaurant at
night like okay that's going on I can
understand that perspective and we all
have to understand that perspective and
the last thing when you talk about this
60 second answers which which is insane
and you know I've been interviewed on TV
before a bunch as well and it's actually
crazy it's when you compare it to a
podcast it's completely crazy that you
have to fit your thoughts and do one
sentence maybe two sentences and the
24-hour news cycle that were on every
news story that comes out is the end of
the world right it's like the end of the
way everything that happens is hey Trump
did this or Pelosi did that this is the
end of the world just like when if if
Hillary got elected it's the end of the
world if Trump gets elected it's the end
of the world it had early on right after
Trump got elected somebody I was doing a
reddit AMA
and as soon as I signed on for my reddit
AMA up pops this question and it's
clearly the guy had spent a lot of time
writing it and it was this this sort of
breakdown of the Russians and Trump and
all this negativity and and you know I
bet I basically took his whole paragraph
and I answered it in one sentence I said
America is stronger than one man and
that's the truth like hey America is
stronger than one man one man is not
going to take down this country that's
that's the way it is right it's hardship
to turn look at what Trump's got
accomplished you know he he's working as
hard as he can to get stuff done and he
could barely move the needle right
that's the way it is and on top of that
look at what happens with our political
system
you know we had Karger oh there's a
backlash against Carter we have Reagan
right oh you know you know these things
go back and forth we end up with Clinton
then we end up with Bush you know the
and then we end up with Obama and
and then we end up with Trump so there's
a balance that happens out so when I
think of my political beliefs or where I
stand politically it's like oh I stand
you you're not gonna be able to place me
very well because I'm gonna listen to
what different people have to say I'm
gonna try and understand what their
perspectives are and then I'm gonna say
oh not what's best for me and what
satisfies my ego but what's good for
America well it actually makes sense for
America and that's what I would move
forward on
[Applause]